ah les mômes quittent
je suis tellement reconnaissant d'être
dans cette salle entourée de mes héros
Brad je t'adore
Quentin
j'ai découvert le scénario de Pulp
Fiction quand j'avais 12 ans j'arrive
pas à y croire merci à la FPA pour cet
honneur je souhaite dire aussi aux
autres nommés que vous avez
sans faire les prestations les plus
profondes et les plus belles et c'est un
honneur pour moi d'être nommé parmi vous
je dois cela
audacieux et visionnaire qui m'a offert
cette expérience qui m'a permis de
prendre des risques que j'ai toujours su
que je serai soutenu base Norman je
t'adore
[Applaudissements]
merci d'avoir cru en moi au moment où
même moi je ne croyais pas en moi-même
je te sais tellement gré je tiens aussi
à remercier
mon meilleur partenaire dedans merci
aussi Denzel Washington Denzel merci
pour ta générosité ta bienveillance
merci de m'avoir défendu quand il
n'était pas obligé merci
je te dois une reconnaissance éternelle
et puis merci à nos producteurs
incroyables Warner Brothers la famille
Presley merci à tous merci d'avoir
ouvert votre cœur vos souvenirs d'avoir
ouvert votre foyer
Marie priscillage vous aime pour toutes
les ternité
vous pourriez au moins jouer ce
speciation mind non
je tiens aussi à remercier ma famille ma
sœur est là à la cheville je t'adore
merci à mon père qui me qui me regarde
chez lui
merci à ma mère qui me regarde là-haut
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir ton
sacrifié pour moi merci et à Elvis
Presley lui-même
tu étais une icône à rebelle je t'aime
tellement merci
on se souvient tous et moi je
n'oublierai jamais merci